I will skip the part
where I brag for three minutes
about how great and cool I am.
Seeing as we are all qualified young men
of skill and character.
-People like that stuff.
-Sounds good, yeah.
People like that stuff a lot.
Some people say they're a sports junkie,
I say, "I'm a politics junkie."
The harder the conflict,
the more glorious the triumph.
I'm playing this like a game.
I would like very much to win.
I love it, boys, I love it. Where you from?
I come from a very modest family.
I'm on the course to be the first one
to graduate from high school.
I'm a progressive person,
and I'm in a room full
of mostly conservative people.
Our masculinity shall not be infringed.
I've never seen so many white people, ever.
I feel like everybody has
this secret underlying need
for bipartisanship.
A message of unity, as good as it sounds,
is not winning anyone any elections.
Primary polls are now open.
Get yourselves ready
for a turbulent election.
Whatever happens to you, best of luck.
You'll win. I support you fully.
My name is Steven Garza,
and I'm running for governor.
A special applause because...
As to the political views
voiced in my speech,
sometimes you gotta say what you gotta say
in an attempt to win.
I think he's a fantastic politician.
But I don't think "a fantastic politician"
is a compliment either.
Yeah! Yeah!
We're gonna do shock and awe.
It's gonna be awesome.
I want you all to take out your phones
and go on Instagram. Everyone, come on.
Oh, my God!
We show the world what patriots are made of,
that when things get tough,
we pull ourselves by our bootstraps,
one nation under God,
lovers of the Constitution
of the United States of America!
That's politics, I think.
That's politics.